vuelve el fragor de las maniobras
militares a taiwán cuando apenas se
había pagado el de las anteriores estas
veces por la visita de una delegación de
políticos estadounidenses encabezada por
ed markey el senador demócrata por
massachusetts y un crítico habitual de
china de hecho ya había liderado la
petición de boicot a los recientes
juegos olímpicos de invierno de pekín la
delegación aterrizó anoche en taipei y
sólo fue anunciada última hora por el
instituto americano de taiwán una
oficina que ejerce test en mi embajada
ya que taiwán y estados unidos carecen
de relaciones oficiales la prensa no ha
sido invitada hoy a la reunión entre la
delegación y la presidenta saben buena
diferencia de lo que sí que había pasado
con la congresista nancy pelosi lo que
parece indicar que está que quiere darle
a este viaje un perfil bajo para
minimizar la respuesta china sin embargo
la respuesta china ha sido todo la
airada que se podía prever la prensa
nacional habla de la prueba definitiva
de las intenciones de eeuu por socavar
la paz en el estrecho de formosa y el
ministerio de defensa ha calificado las
maniobras militar ordenadas hoy como una
solemne disuasión contra todos los actos
provocadores de taipei washington